[Music]
on this saturday night bracing for more
rain in bc's flood zone
shoring up with sandbags the water is
actually going to come from
south of the border anxious residents
pack their bags ready to run again i'm a
little bit scared about all the rain
coming
ominous omicron we need to slow down the
spread of this variant the race to beat
this new kova 19 variant the military's
new top boss that speaks to this not
being just a woman's issue it's an issue
for all of us to address how this
general plans to get soldiers in line
[Music]
plus the tribute to canadian actor ryan
reynolds
global national with robin gill
good evening and thank you for joining
us we begin tonight on the wet west
coast where another storm system is
bearing down that atmospheric river is
once again drenching southwestern
british columbia environment canada has
issued its first red level alert as much
as a hundred and twenty millimeters of
rain could fall
global's heather york's west is in
abbotsford bc where residents are still
dealing with the cleanup from another
flood heather
yeah robin it has been raining very
heavily here all day today abbotsford's
mayor warning that the city could see
120 millimeters by tomorrow morning but
for residents of this part of the city
it's not so much what's falling from the
sky that's a concern it's what may be
heading here from south of the border
the nooksack river in washington state
partly responsible for the devastating
flooding that occurred in this region
last week is now expected to flood its
banks a second time this weekend
dozens of members of canada's military
helping to get abbotsford through the
incoming storm our mission is to build a
wall along this train track on the south
side
roughly two feet high what we're trying
to do is redirect the water away from
the people
so that they have more options the
neighborhood of huntington village has
been through this before denise shindak
was evacuated from her home for several
days last week as water filled her yard
and garage we tried to pack up as many
things as we could remember
we have two dogs two
cats so it was pretty frantic
but this community is on alert again
under threat of flooding from the nucsac
river across the border in washington
state damage to the river's levee system
has left surrounding communities
vulnerable to flooding and that includes
residents here on the canadian side
i'm
a little bit scared about all the rain
coming
but i see they're doing a lot of work
down here at the railroad tracks so
hopefully it can stop the water it's
just one area of concern as parts of
flood ravaged bc brace for back to back
storms on saturday afternoon the
province closed several portions of
major highways between bc's lower
mainland and the interior heavy rain
expected through the region posing too
much of a risk to travelers i have
committed from the beginning that we
will be here for whatever is needed
after touring the region friday canada's
prime minister along with bc premier
john horgan announced the formation of a
joint committee to address disaster
response and climate resilience the
governments are also promising to match
dollar for dollar donations to the red
cross we need to rebuild more resilient
infrastructure that's going to be able
to handle
100-year storms every few years because
that seems to be the pattern we're on
both levels of government are promising
to support bc residents as they clean up
and rebuild but for now the focus is on
the next potential flood
and right now members of the military
are still working to shore up this
sandbag dike in preparation for water
that could be coming into the community
tomorrow residents of this neighborhood
right beside me in huntington village
have been warned that they may have to
evacuate with very little notice it's
going to be a very tense weekend as the
rain just continues to fall robin
heather yorks west in abbotsford bc
thanks heather it is estimated that the
bill for the flooded farms in bc will
run into the billions of dollars beyond
the financial impact there's the
emotional toll on the farmers themselves
many have been working the land or the
family business for generations as nithu
garcia reports there's so much at stake
in the recovery process
it's hard to put into words
depression
sadness
the work of three generations of avatar
sandhu's family including his son and
nephews is now underwater everything our
parents have built up and
our aunts and uncles or grandparents
just wash it just to watch it get washed
away it's heartbreaking i myself have
inventory in my cooler
cauliflower just floating around with
millions of dollars and a western
canadian hub of fresh local vegetable
and berry produce at stake they're
determined to bounce back
we just need all the help we can get
right now this is devastating
you know where you can't even get into
your homes
your tractors are all under water but we
won't give up for the gill family 32
acres of blueberries have been wiped out
they're just one of nearly 60 blueberry
producers impacted in the fraser valley
you know it takes 10 years to get where
we were before this flood flood
insurance is not offered here on the
plains
these families still evacuated from
their homes and farms have been able to
survey some damage by boat and to give
you an idea of how unrecognizable this
landscape remains this is where the
abbotsford tulip festival used to be the
owners of this property still in shock
and feeling like all of this could have
been prevented the tula festival and our
other neighbors with perennials
is all gone in one day
sucks that you hear that there was a
lack of maintenance i don't know if
that's true but if it is that's
i'm disappointed in our government amid
allegations of a lack of dyke
maintenance to blame for this level of
catastrophe generations of family
farmers in the sumas prairie hope their
tragedy leads to a more proactive plan
if we rebuild and this happens again
it's all just going to be in vain it's
your entire livelihood
we'll come back stronger that prevents
their livelihoods from once again
becoming casualties of a changing
climate nitu garcia global news
abbotsford bc
more residents of merit are able to
return home today and assess the flood
damage in that part of bc the city of 7
000 is allowing people back in phases
merit was completely evacuated during
the floods nearly two weeks ago some
residents are furious with how long it's
taken to get back to their homes
we come from a redneck town how many of
us put a pair of steel toes on every day
to fix this place we could have been
doing that
the flooding caused the city's water
treatment facility to fail it's now back
on track still residents will have to
boil and limit their water usage
there is still no date of return for
people living in what's called the flood
inundation zone
to the kova 19 pandemic and the concerns
over the newly discovered omicron
variant the uk germany italy and the
netherlands have all confirmed cases of
the heavily mutated variant of concern
first discovered in south africa
although researchers are still trying to
determine whether omicron is more
transmissible governments around the
world are restricting flights from
several southern african nations that
includes this country while health
canada says there are no known cases
here canada's top doctor says it could
only be a matter of time michael couture
explains
[Music]
just hours after the uk confirmed two
cases of the omicron variant prime
minister boris johnson implemented swift
and sweeping measures we will also go
further in asking all of you to help
contain the spread of this variant by
tightening up the rules on face
coverings in shops and on public
transport little is known about the two
cases but the british health minister
says they are linked the uk is banning
travel from a number of countries we are
adding four more countries to the red
list from 4am on sunday
and those are angola mozambique malawi
and zambia that's in addition to the six
other southern africa countries already
on the red list the people are getting
more and more upset paula zimmerman had
returned to the netherlands from south
africa which is on the uk's list she
describes a chaotic scene with the plane
being held on the tarmac for hours long
lines for covid19 testing and then a
shock i thought everybody who was in
that queue there was tested negatively
but we were waiting there for the bus
and after 20 minutes i heard
that the guy next to me
was tested positive friday canada's top
doctor said health officials continue to
search for possible cases in this
country but so far none have been found
in post-arrival screening of
international travelers for the
individual in ontario and in canada
there's no change get your vaccines when
you're eligible keep wearing your mask
keep adhering to public health measures
and and we'll be okay we actually will
be the uk is doing all that plus
boosting the booster shot program the
world health organization has called for
a moratorium on widespread booster
programs until there is vaccine equity
across the globe
so far canada isn't following britain's
lead our health minister said the health
of canadians has been the priority while
also helping others we have not only
promised
200 million doses over the next year to
countries that need their population to
vaccinate but we've already started to
deliver
millions of doses to those countries
those deliveries are key as health
officials stress the pandemic won't be
over in canada until it's over
everywhere across the globe
mike lacrouter global news ottawa
starting monday the u.s will also
restrict all travelers coming from that
part of africa with the exception of
american citizens there haven't been any
confirmed cases of the omicron variant
in the u.s yet but the nation is already
grappling with rising caseloads in
dozens of states as jennifer johnson
reports overwhelmed hospitals are being
forced to make drastic decisions
as kobe 19 cases surge again across much
of the u.s president joe biden made the
southern africa travel ban decision he
called the move cautious but did it on
the advice of federal medical experts we
don't know
a lot about the variant except that it
is a great concern it seems to spread
rapidly
michigan hospitals are so overwhelmed
with cover 19 patients the federal
government is sending doctors and nurses
to the state to reinforce medical staff
the governor of massachusetts has
ordered hospitals running out of beds
because of cover 19 to cancel elective
surgeries starting next week as a health
care worker really devastating to have
to make people wait for so long to get
care that they really do need similar
orders have been made in maine and new
york at this long island hospital the
emergency room has been temporarily
closed because there are too many
patients and too few nurses with hardly
any notice this was thrust upon us in
our community erie county new york just
recorded its highest daily number of new
coven 19 cases ever icu beds are
becoming scarce unfortunately we are
going in the wrong direction and this is
the worst direction we've ever had the
increase in cases and hospitalizations
comes as doctors prepare for another
coba 19 surge following the busy
thanksgiving holiday and christmas time
celebrations the battle goes on with
about 30 percent of america's adult
population still not vaccinated our fate
is in our own hands it is absolutely
essential that unvaccinated people get
vaccinated and the vaccinated people get
boosters
daily infections are now rising by at
least 10 percent in 35 states and now
there's the threat of that new and
potentially more transmissible variant
which many doctors believe is likely
already in the u.s
jennifer johnson global news washington
coming up how canada's top general will
address sexual misconduct in canada's
military
canada officially has a new chief of the
defense staff general wayne ayer's
appointment comes at a crucial time for
the canadian armed forces in addition to
operational challenges responding to
severe weather events on two canadian
coasts he faces internal challenges
around the military's reckoning with
sexual misconduct general ayer joins
mercedes stevenson this week on the west
block mercedes what did he have to say
about reshaping military culture
robin general wayne ayer has been tasked
with overhauling the culture of the
canadian armed forces to deal with what
experts have described as toxic power
dynamics and an ongoing sexual
misconduct scandal
ayer was candid in his first interview
with the west block since being
appointed permanent chief of the defense
staff saying there's a long road ahead
for the military and that he's not sure
that anyone would want the job of top
soldier right now given the
circumstances in the canadian armed
forces ayers says however he is honored
to lead canadian troops
heirs appointment comes at a crucial
time for the military nearly 19 000
individual claimants have come forward
in the class-action lawsuit settlement
for survivors of military sexual
misconduct for air the types of claims
being brought forward speak volumes
about the depth of cultural problems in
the forces i think it's also important
to notice to note that
the latest stats i've seen 42 percent
are men and that speaks to this not
being just a woman's issue it's an issue
for all of us to address it's an issue
of power dynamics as well that that
speak to a an element that we have to
fix air initially took on the role as
acting chief of the defense staff in
february when admiral art macdonald had
to step aside after finding out he was
under investigation for sexual assault
allegations
the investigation ended with no charges
due to insufficient evidence according
to the military police
mcdonnell then began a campaign to be
reinstated and claimed that he was
exonerated by the military police police
said that was not the case and they did
not deem the allegation to be unfounded
mcdonald denies any wrongdoing the
situation however created an
embarrassing conundrum for the
government with two top commanders
making a claim for the same job on
thursday the government said they had
lost confidence in art mcdonald and that
air would assume the rule permanently
the military had refused to answer
questions about whether mcdonald could
still face administrative action which
has been used against other personnel
accused of sexual misconduct who were in
some cases forcibly discharged from the
military
i put the question of whether
administrative action is a possibility
to general air
what has happened is between adam
macdonald and the government i've
deliberately kept myself at arm's length
from that that process and
he's indicated that he's releasing from
the military so
that that will unfold air did not say
why the military was not looking into
administrative action for admiral
mcdonald you can watch the full
interview with general air tomorrow on
the west walk robin mercedes stevenson
in ottawa thanks mercedes
up next ethiopia's president won a nobel
peace prize but can he keep the peace in
his own country
[Applause]
protesters and police clashed in burkina
faso's capitol today hundreds of people
took to the streets demanding the
country's president resign they're angry
at the government's inability to stem
violence linked to al-qaeda and the
so-called islamic state conflict is
common in burkina faso but there's been
an escalation of violent attacks since
the beginning of november
the federal government is urging all
canadians in ethiopia to leave the
country immediately the security
situation in the east african nation is
rapidly deteriorating a year-long
conflict between government forces and
rebel fighters from the northern tigray
region has spread closer to the capital
prime minister abi ahmed is vowing to be
victorious and claims to be directing
the military from the front lines as
redmond shannon reports international
efforts to broker a ceasefire have made
little progress
old veterans saluting new recruits as
they join an ethiopian army badly in
need of a boost
i'm not afraid to die he says this man
it's for my country
prime minister abi ahmed has looked to
inspire such support vowing to lead from
the front lines of the civil war himself
some of ethiopia's revered olympic
runners like haile gabriel selassie have
promised to do the same
government forces allied with the amhara
ethnic group are primarily fighting
against the tigray people's liberation
front or tplf from the northern tigray
region in recent weeks the tplf has been
getting closer to the capital addis
ababa
as rebels from abbey's own ethnic group
the oromo liberation army are also
fighting against his government forces
abbey has won a nobel prize for his
peace deal with eritrea
when he took power in 2018 it sidelined
the tplf which had spent 27 years as
part of an authoritarian regime they now
feel frozen out and dominated they are
suggesting that ethiopia is an empire it
cannot be a homogeneous state it cannot
be a country where national identity can
be defined
along one ethnic groups or the roma or
tyrion
ethiopian academic gabas genamo believes
the tplf could reach the capital but
taking africa's diplomatic hub is
another matter technically i think they
can
but i don't think the international
community
would allow them to do but the tyrians
also hesitate to do that now many people
do not want to see them at growing
ethiopia again
because their experience of 27 years was
mostly not positive under this month's
state of emergency hundreds more ethnic
tigrans and even some u.n staff have
been detained so it's not only ethnic to
giants but we've also been receiving
reports of oromos being arrested in
addis and the outskirts across the
country millions have been displaced and
hundreds of thousands are living in
famine conditions with many aid routes
blocked african leaders and the u.s have
been trying to get the sides to peace
talks prime minister justin trudeau has
twice spoken to abby this month calling
for a cease-fire until there is any
progress much of the suffering will
continue far behind the front lines
redmond shannon global news london
there is a worrying situation in the
south pacific australia has sent in
military support to the solomon islands
after days of unrest turned deadly
police found three burned bodies after
buildings in the capital's chinatown
district were looted and torched more
than 100 people have been arrested and
an overnight curfew is in effect
protesters have been calling for the
country's prime minister to resign some
of the anger stems from the government's
2019 decision to sever its diplomatic
relationship with taiwan in favor of
beijing
a genuine canadian icon
canadian shows a little love for another
canuck
[Music]
they said brian adams was busy
and nickelback all had to work
they meant to call drake but called me
by mistake till you're struck with a
song by this jerk
that's stephen page of the barenaked
ladies serenading ryan reynolds the
canadian actor was being honored at the
governor general's performing arts
awards the virtual ceremony celebrated
catherine o'hara as well the shit's
creek star received this year's lifetime
achievement award and her co-stars
helped with the honor
catherine you are in a few words or less
one of a kind i see a canadian icon
whose
shining star
rivals
the northern lights
i love you congratulations
and to wrap it up noah reed of shits
creek performed a rendition of joni
mitchell's a case of you while wearing a
few of o'hara's trademark wigs from the
show
hilarious and that is global national
for this saturday night i'm robin gill
tonight your canada is van dusen gardens
in vancouver all decked out and lit up
for the holidays we would love to see
your corner of the country so please
keep sending your photos to viewers at
globalnational.com
thank you for watching and i'll see you
back here tomorrow have a great night
[Music]
[Music]
you